und damit sind wir gestern beim Thema
Selbstschädigung da gebe ich gebe ich
Ihnen völlig Recht vor Kelle was was in
der deutschen was in der deutschen
Energiepolitik lief über die ganzen
Jahre weg war immer schon unverständlich
und im Nachhinein wird es besonders
absurd aber das ist jetzt vergossene
Milch wir waren in dieser Situation dann
wäre jetzt nur die Frage gewesen die äh
dass man gesagt hätte okay weil wir so
abhängig sind von den Russen beteiligen
wir uns nicht an den Sanktionen zu den
Sanktionen habe ich eine habe ich eine
doppelte Meinung ich sage als
als Ökonom sie können gar nicht wirken
damit werde ich gerade bestätigt als der
Politiker oder als politische Städten
der Mensch sage ich wir hatten überhaupt
keine Wahl als die Sanktionen zu machen
damit müssen wir jetzt durch auch wenn
es nachteilig ist
Russland Moment die helfen Russland nur
ganz kurzfristig denn russland hat hat
die Märkte im Westen auf die Dauer
verloren dafür
das hat die Märkte auf Dauer verloren
und wenn wir diesen Winter überstanden
haben und den nächsten haben Sommer
überstanden haben dann werden wir auch
eine neue Basis haben für unsere dafür
unsere Energieversorgung ohne Russland
allerdings eine teure Basis und das ist
das Thema wir haben jetzt ein Problem
mit dieser Übergangszeit die objektiv
schwierig ist und auch fast unlösbar ist
weil man nicht weiß ob das Gas am Ende
reicht ob der Strom reicht und so weiter
da haben wir ein Thema und da gebe ich
Ihnen wiederum recht wo wir schauen
müssen dass wir dass wir den Bürgern
Sicherheit geben der Bürger egal ob wir
jetzt ob wir jetzt ein der
mittelständischer Bäcker ist wie er von
Robert Habeck erwähnt wurde bei
Maischberger der braucht natürlich der
muss natürlich dass eine Energie
bezahlen wollen wer seine Brötchen
bezahlbar sein muss und die Rentnerin um
die Ecke beim Bäcker muss in der Lage
sein die Brötchen zu kaufen weil sie
nicht von ihrer Gasrechnung erschlagen
deshalb müssen wir nachdem das so ist
wie es jetzt müssen wir einfach als
Staat sagen wir schaffen
im Gas und Strommarkt eine preisaufsicht
eine staatliche preisaufsicht ist
irgendwas auch mal gab das ist ja nichts
Neues sie ist abgeschafft worden die
wird jetzt wieder eingeführt und das
bedeutet dass die dass die dass die
Preise für den für das für die für die
Unternehmen vor allem für die
mittelständischen Unternehmen und für
den Normalverbraucher im Rahmen normaler
Verbrauchsmengen eben nicht ins
Ungemessene steigen können sondern sagen
wir mal im Verhältnis dort zur Zeit vor
dem 24 februar und vielleicht 20 30
Prozent
Frage stellen ja eine Verständnisfrage
schwebt ihn jetzt hier beispielsweise
das Modell wie in Großbritannien vor was
es dort seit 2019 gibt mit Blick auf die
Energiepreise oder welches Modell würden
Sie gerne umsetzen ich denke nicht ab
vom Modell ich hänge ab am Ergebnis
nämlich dass das die dass die
also dass die Rentnerin Meier ja die
vielleicht die vielleicht
1100 Euro Rente bekommt da hatte ich
schon viel und mit ihren und vielleicht
80 Euro Gasrechnung hat von der
Rentnerin 1.150
aber können wir einmal den Politik und
auch wirtschaftschef der Bild einmal
fragen nach einer sachlichen
Einschätzung wie dieses Modell umsetzbar
überhaupt wäre ja ich finde das sehr
spannend wie wir hier diskutieren und
freue mich auch und ähm muss in Teilen
zudem auch zustimmen was was Sie gesagt
haben Herr Sarrazin ich glaube dass der
Preis ja wissen Sie als Volkswirt
ebenfalls noch viel besser
wahrscheinlich als ich ja ein ganz ganz
wichtiger Mechanismus ist und das sage
ich erstmal nur ganz generell Preise
immer wichtig und deswegen gibt es
beispielsweise auch eine CO2 Umlage ja
mal eingeführt worden damit der
Energieverbrauch der fossile
Energieverbrauch teurer wird in der
Hoffnung dass die Menschen Ihren
Verbrauch senken so jetzt haben wir eine
dramatische Preissteigerung vollkommen
richtig und jetzt ist die Frage wie
begegnet man dir am besten
und da ist Ihr Modell sicherlich
spannend ich fürchte nur dass wenn man
es so macht es extreme Kosten gibt die
am Ende wir alle als Steuerzahler
irgendwie bezahlen müssen das heißt die
Frage ist gehen wir an die Preise ran
oder gibt es besser nicht direkte und
dann auch stärkere und nicht mit der
Gießkanne verteilte direkte Hilfen für
die die es wirklich nötig haben und dann
mag es so sein dass 300 Euro für ein
rentnerhaushalt oder ein Rentner nicht
ausreichen vielleicht müssen es tausend
sein vielleicht müssen auch 2000 sein
ich glaube bloß dass dieser
Preismechanismus im Prinzip ein ganz
ganz wichtiger ist und wir sehen immer
wieder wenn Preismechanismus ausgesetzt
wird beispielsweise in Berlin beim Thema
mieten mietpreisdeckel dann passiert
folgendes der Markt gerät aus den Fugen
und zwar anders als es die Sozialisten
wollen es werden sich mehr Wohnungen
gebaut es werden interessanterweise was
gar kein Wunder deswegen klicke ich
immer dafür vielleicht sind sie auch
dran den Preismechanismus möglichst zu
halten und dann zu gucken und was kann
man zusätzlich so an Hilfen geben an
Menschen oder Firmen ganz wichtig ich
die ist ganz ganz dringend ich wollte
sagen ich gebe Ihnen da eigentlich recht
was den Preismechanismus angeht im
Prinzip nicht
sondern ich sage ja auch also der 20 30
Prozent preisaktik dem wissen alle
tragen und wir müssen schauen wo wird
denn der reale Öl der reale Gas und der
Strompreis liegen wenn das wenn das
ganze hinter uns liegt in meinen Wegen
24 Monaten irgendwo
irgendwo höher sein als heute aber auch
nicht irgendwo im Himmel und auf diesen
Preis muss man jetzt mittelfristig
Zielen und da muss man jetzt jetzt den
Bäcker denn nämlich dafür seinen
Backofen wahrscheinlich im Monat 2000
bis 2000 € bisher zahlt für das für das